[music playing] [countdown begins] [Android
noise] [airplane sound] [countdown ends]
>>Joe Malin: Welcome once again to Android
Developer Office Hours.
My name is Joe Malin.
I'll be your moderator today.
Next to me is Trevor Johnsó
>>Trevor Johns: Hi.
>>Malin: And also with me is Alex Lucas.
We have Tim Bray also here, and Daniel Pham
is our engineer.
There's Tim.
So without further ado, let's get started
with questions from Google Moderator.
We have several questions on the order of
sensors of fragmentation.
I'll read them and then let Tim and others
answer.
"Can some sensor testing be introduced on
devices that Google approves by allowing the
play store on the device?
This would then show more standardized behavior.
Many LG and Samsung accelerometers return
the same invalid value when the screen is
off."
And there's other questions to that regard,
as well.
Somebody want to answer?
>>Tim Bray: Yeah, I'll address that.
Can people hear me?
>>Joe: Yep!
>>Alex Lucas: Yep!
>>Tim: Okay, fair enough.
To start with, it's even worse than you think
it is, because if you look carefully at the
Android compatible device definition, it doesn't
actually require that an Android device have
any sensors at all.
One of the reasons for that is that it also
[unintelligible, mic interference] that aren't
going to have accelerometers or anything like
that.
It's absolutely keythe case, as far as your
correct code, that depends on sensors, you're
going to have to do some probing and testing
to see if the sensor is there.
You may even want to get a little bit more
subtle, because people who've done this kind
of stuff have noticed that if you're doing
motion related stuff, it makes a big difference
whether the phone has a gyroscope or not.
You get domestic immensely better quality
if there's a gyroscope.
{For some cases, you might even be inclined
to round, with a gyroscope, for example.}
Now, having said all that, what the person
was asking hereó"Jann, Jahn," something like
thatóJan, are you one of the people we can
see?
If so, wave.
>>Joe: No, doesn't look like it.
>>Dan: Not as far as I can tell.
>>Joe: Nope.
>>Tim: Okay.
Somebody else just joined.
Anyhow, what Jan's really driving at was:
should we try and crack down on operativeapparent
incompatibilities between one model and the
next?
If you ask me, the current Compatibility Test
Suite does have some tests that I've tried
on a few devices, and they're actually pretty
good for accelerometer and gyroscope.
In particular, when I used them, I noticed
some little quirksperks that I've observed
in particular hardware.
But not that many.
There's also some basic tests that Dave and
I do to check.
So let me say a few things in general.
First of all, empirically, I see that there's
quite a few decent apps out there that make
excellent use of the sensors, in particular
the accelerometer and the gyroscope.
So whereas there are some compatibility issues
here, we see that people have successfully
worked around them and got really good results.
So yeah, it may be a little harder than we'd
all like it to be, but you can actually do
it.
Another thing I should point out is that the
Compatibility Test Suite is one of the most
open source-y parts of Android.
The whole thing is open source.
It's developed in an open source way.
And anybody who observes something they think
is really wonky in an Android device: "Hey,
it would be a really good idea to pull together
a test and submit it to the project."
I suspect those guys will seem quite open
to looking at it.
The final point somebody made was that they
observed issues where sensors were giving
wonky values when the screen was off, which
means probably that the device is just lying
there, not doing anything.
I hadn't actually noticed that.
I looked around, I also didn't see actually
any live bug file on that one.
Perhaps the reason there is that all work
that I did on Samsung program was waiting
to sitwaving the thing around on capturing---
[voices coming through the computer]
>>Trevor: That's an interesting noise coming
from the Hangout there.
[voices continue] Do you just want to mute
everyone else, Dan?
>>Dan Pham: Yeah, I'm going to go--
>>Trevor: And just a reminder for those of
you who are joining us liveó
>>Joe: Hold on for a second, Tim.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
Just a reminder for those of you who are joining
us live, please mute your microphone when
you're not speaking.
There's a little button in the upper right
hand corner of Google+.
Go ahead and hit that.
Otherwise, it gets a little bit hard to hear
what people are saying in here.
[voices from computers]
>>Joe: I'm still hearing something.
>>Trevor: Yeah, we can hear somebody laughing.
Hello!
>>Tim: It's the gentlemen with the black hair
and the red shirt there.
[pause]
>>Dan: All right, don't worry.
I'm on it, guys.
Just do your thing.
>>Joe: Okay.
Right.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Tim: Okay, so where was I?
So yeah, there were complaints about devices,
complaints when things are asleep.
I'm sorry, I can't speak to that one.
I haven't observed that one.
There may, in fact, be bugs there.
I'll tell you, I do not look if there are
tests in the CTS of that.
>>Joe: Okay.
>>Tim: So that's something you should look
at.
>>Joe: I would add that if you are using sensors
and you run into something which you think
is a bug, or just not working the way you
think it should be working, you should file
a bug.
Okay?
You know, not everything that's out there
that you encounter is deliberate.
So when in doubt, you should file a bug.
It's either a bug or it's some aspect of expected
behavior.
And if it is a bug, we can get to fixing or
addressing it.
Any other comments?
[pause]
>>Trevor: No, I think that's good.
>>Joe: All right.
Let me move to the next question on Moderator,
unless we have somebody in the Hangout that
wants to ask a question.
Hmm?
Nope.
>>Trevor: We do have a pretty full Hangout.
Also, yeah, just a reminder for those of you
who are joining us live: you are welcome to
join us via Hangout, ask questions.
We're here to answer them.
If you are joining via the Hangout, we assume
that you are going to ask a question.
We only have ten slots at a time.
It looks like it's getting pretty full, so
we're going to ask those ten of you to actually
start asking questions here in short order.
Otherwise, we'll have to start kicking some
of you off to make room for people who do
have questions.
That being said, the live feed is available
via Youtube as well, so that way, everybody
who is watching and doesn't have a question
can view us that way.
>>Joe: Right.
In summary, if you want to watch and be ready
to ask a question if you've got one, go to
Youtube.
>>Trevor: No, go to Hangout if they have a
question.
>>Joe: Well, hold on.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Joe: If you don't have a question right
now, go to Youtube and you can watch live.
Then, if you've got a question, jump into
the Hangout.
If you're waiting to ask a question, stay
in the Hangout.
>>Trevor: Right.
>>Joe: Okay?
Do we have any questions waiting?
>>Dan: We have a Jared.
I'm going to put him on momentarily.
>>Joe: Okay.
>>Dan: All right, Jared, you're on.
Go ahead.
>>Jared: In my halfapp, I'm working with a
whole bunch of background threads, and I'm
starting to really have some issues with race
conditions and trying to figure out which
thread is doing what, that sort of thing.
I just started looking at Traceview a couple
days ago, and it is incredibly difficult to
try and make any sense of what it actually
gives me.
Is there a recommended practice or a different
tool, perhaps, that might make a little more
sense?
>>Trevor: Traceview is more for performance
optimization.
It gives you an idea of when your app is drawing
to the screen, when it is actually using CPU,
things like that.
It's not so good at seeing interactions between
threads.
And really, there's not too much that's really
going to do a good job of visualizing that
for you.
Your best tool, really, there, is the debugger
built into your IDE, whether it's Eclipse
or IntelliJ or using the Java debugger on
the command line.
Race conditions are always notoriously difficult
to debug.
They're always a little bit painful, unfortunately,
and that's just the nature of concurrent programming.
I really don't have too much to say that's
gonna make that really easy for you, other
than use a standard debugger and try and sort
things out that way.
I assume this is just an ordinary race condition
within your code.
There's nothing having to do with the GPE
oró
>>Jared: Yeah.
So really, what's happening is that I have
a class that takes messages for data to post
to the database in batches.
Under certain conditions, it actually slows
down the UI.
I'm presuming because I'm synchronizing data,
you can have cert function calls and stuff
like that.
>>Trevor: Okay, so, well, if it's slowing
down the UIóYour UI should be on a self-contained
UI thread.
You shouldn't begin any data operations there.
>>Jared: Right.
Which it is.
But I think that what's happening is when
it goes to actually write the data to the
database, it synchronizes on the class.
And I think that the UI is unable to get data
from it.
>>Trevor: Oh, okay.
Gotcha.
>>Jared: I'm trying to verify that.
>>Tim: Right.
I did a ton of research on concurrency a couple
years ago.
A few remarks: if the Java model of concurrency,
which all Android inherits is sorta pessimal.
It allows for shared computable state, which
makes multi-threaded things really, really
hard to think about and understand.
And you start to have a lot of different mutexes
and so on.
You're very likely gonna end up in a situation
where it's gonna become nearly impossible
to understand what's going on.
One thing I would strongly recommend would
be to go and read a couple of good, short
essays on functional programming, which is
the best technique we know about to avoid
having to  to the extent that
you've made your code truly functional.
You dodge all this kind of stuff.
I would also go type the name Doug Lea, D-Doug
L-E-A, into Google and read a couple of his
things that he wrote.
He is maybe our leading thinker on how to
do this stuff without sticking your head up
your ass, which I've done a few times.
Probably there's some really helpful stuff
in there.
One particular thing I will say is that if
you can go through one of the built in things
like AsyncTask or IntentService or something
like that, they are really, really fully debugged
on this stuff.
They are less likely to barf on your thread
pools and code you write yourself.
>>Joe: Right.
I have a question about thisóJared, right?
Which is, you're trying to run multiple threads
to write to the database?
>>Jared: Well, specifically, the model is:
I have a thread that manages all the access
to the database.
It's my single connection with the database.
>>Joe: Aha.
>>Jared: And it basically, in its run loop,
it at the start of it checks to see if there's
any pending data to write.
If there is, it writes it.
Then it sleeps for a certain amount of time.
Meanwhile, other things can post the data
in, but there'sówhen it goes to write the
data, I have it synchronize on itself, which
may actually be where the problem is.
>>Joe: Hmm.
>>Jared: But my idea was I didn't want it
toóBecause there's a lot of data, it's weather
data, I don't want it to start arriving and
then get an update halfway through and write
stuff that doesn't correspond to the same
timestamp.
So I'm trying to figure out if maybe there's
a way that I can read data without synchronizing
on it, but write data withoutóyeah.
That's what I'm trying to figure out.
>>Joe: I understand.
>>Tim: I would alsoóI just looked, and I
noticed that the Android SDK includes the
java.util.concurrent class.
>>Jared: Mmhmm.
>>Tim: I think you might be well-served by
going and diving into that pond and lookingóIt
gives you things like thread pools, synchronization,
and queues that will {}exhaust part of the
queue.
It's all well, well, well debugged code.
>>Jared: Okay.
>>Tim: And to the extent that you can use
that, that might help.
>>Joe: Jared, are you doing this work right
now on an AsyncTask?
>>Jared: No, the problem I have with the AsyncTask
is because that's all basically a thread pool.
I have other parts that function on the UI
that use AsyncTask, and it was interfering
with that.
I couldn't do the database write and maintainóat
least, I couldn't think of a way of maintaining
the one connection to the database through
an AsyncTask, and make sure that all the writing
happened in the background.
>>Joe: Ah, okay.
>>Jared: I'll probably, you knowó
>>Joe: Yeah.
It's a difficult one to answer because without
knowing more about what exactly you're trying
to do, you wouldó
>>Jared: Right.
I'm trying toóI mean, I could use a content
provider.
I'm sure that would simplify a lot of things.
But I don't actually have need of a content
provider, aside fromó
>>Joe: Yeah, I don'tóI honestlyó
>>Tim: If it makes you feel any better, what
you're trying to do is well-known to be a
hard thing.
>>Jared: Right.
I know that.
I mean, originally, I programmed in C++, so
it's even worse.
[all laugh] I was hoping there might be some
sort of tool that is specifically for monitoring
threads.
>>Joe: No.
And I don't think a content provider would
help you all that much because that's just
a lightweight-- in a lot of respects, it's
just a lightweight shell around the database
anyway.
You start to run into the problems that you're
running into.
>>Jared: Yeah.
Basically, I tried to implement my own thread
pool around the database, and I probably just
didn't do a very good job of it.
>>Joe: Mmm.
Okay.
Any other comments or ideas that we can provide?
[pause]
>>Trevor: I think that's covered quite a bit.
[chuckles]
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Jared: I'll take a look at the concurrent
classes.
That sounds like it might be a good place
to start.
>>Joe: Okay.
Thank you very much for your patience.
>>Jared: Yeah, thank you.
>>Dan: All right, so we have another user
in the Hangout who wants to ask a question.
His name is Martin.
I'm going to put Martin on.
>>Joe: Please.
Please do.
[pause] Hello, Martin.
>>Martin: Hey guys.
>>Trevor: Howdy.
>>Martin: Oh, hey.
I want to touch the sensors a little more,
since that's basically the topic today.
[laughs] YouWe were talking about the accelerometer
in particular not working in the background
of some devices, right?
So there's, I mean, there is a ton of devices
send reports just surrounding that but there's
also a fairly easy solution that works on
some devices.
Basically restart the accelerometer when you
receive a screen-off broadcast.
The problem there isóThe question would beóIn
some devices, even that does not work.
So if you hold the partial wakelock on the
device, should that let me restart the accelerometer
or not?
>>Trevor: That's a good question.
I don't think the behavior there is actually
specified as part of the API.
I suspect what you've probably found is something
that works by chance, but not by design.
[laughs]
>>Martin: Oh.
>>Trevor: It's difficult to say exactly.
Just to be clear, when you say "in the background,",
do you mean your app is no longer in foreground,
or do you mean you've shut the phone completely
off?
>>Martin: I mean, it doesn't even matter if
the app is in the foreground or background.
Basically, it is a service, so it shouldn't
make any difference.
You justóWhat you notice is on some phones,
when you press the power button and you turn
the screen off, that automatically shuts down
the accelerometer as well.
So what you do is you is you basically listen
for the screen-off broadcast.
You actually need to wait for a couple of
seconds, and then restart the accelerometer,
right?
So the expected behavior or the documented
thing would be events for the wakelock, right?
The partial wakelock should keep at least
the processor running, and I would expect
that by default, it would enable you to enable
other stuff as well, right?
>>Trevor: [laughs] That would have been my
expectation as well, yes.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Martin: I'm justóIt feels like it's not
enabled, or it works by chance.
It feels like it's disabled by design [laughs]
on some of the devices.
>>Tim: I wouldn't be surprised, you know.
The  doesn't say anything about that.
>>Trevor: Right.
>>Tim: I could imagine some system builder
deciding to just turn it off when the power
goes off, because it's a sort of self-defense
against developers who don't do the right
thing.
[laughs]
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: So when I say, "It works by chance,"
I'm not saying that you're running into some
scenario that hasn't been conceived of somewhere
by some engineer.
It's just not part of the standard Android
design.
We specify what things need to look like at
the surface level, what the API to developers
looks like.
But as far as how things like device drivers
are implemented, a lot of that is left up
to device manufacturers out of necessity.
And it's possible somebody just thought, "Oh,
leaving the accelerometer running when the
screen is off consumes a lot of battery power,
so let's just go in a terminate theany accelerometer
listeners that are waiting."
The probably justómaybe they didn't think
of the implications of that, or maybe they
really don't want you to do that.
Who knows.
But in any case, it's notóthe behavior here
isn't something that we specify in the API.
I do agree, though, that the right thing,
probably, is to leave the accelerometer running
as long as you hold a wakelock.
Generally speaking, when you run into bugs
like this, we want to get something into the
CDDV and the CTS to go and make sure that
the behavior is really well specified.
Basically, that means filing a bug.
So if you go to b.android.com, that's usually
oura recommendation.
Open a bug there, and if you're really ambitious,
you can actually go so far as to submit a
patch.
Since you brought this up here, I'll make
sure that thosedoes get filed for you.
Now, which device in particular were you working
with?
>>Martin: [sighs] I have an Excel spreadsheet
somewhere.
[laughs] I can send it to you.
ëCauseó
>>Tim: But just generally: do most of them
turn off or do most of them stay on?
>>Martin: I would say it's kinda a 50/50 situation.
>>Tim: Ah!
No kidding.
>>Martin: Yeah.
So it worksóI had problems, actually, on
a Google device.
I think the Galaxy S-- or the Nexus S, pardon,
was problematic in that regard.
>>Joe: What's the use case?
I'm assuming that you want to be able to control
when the acceleratoróor, at least, detect
when the accelerator's gonna turn off by saying,
"If I have a wakelock, then it shouldn't turn
off."
So what are you trying to accomplish by this?
>>Martin: Here's the use case.
I want to monitoróLet's say, let's pretend
I want to monitor activity during the day.
So I have a service that's in the background,
and every time you turn off the screen, the
accelerometer goes off.
What we do here in our case is we acquire
a new wakelock, a new partial wakelock, ëcause
it appears that you need to acquire a new
one, ëcause the old one, wannabe, expired.
That happened in several devices.
[clears throat] So listen for the screen-off
broadcast.
You acquire a new wakelock the same second.
You wait for-- I think waiting for three seconds
was the sweet spot.
And then you go to the accelerometer and say,
"Hey!
Start now."
And then it's on.
In 99.5% of the cases, it actually works.
Some devicesó
>>Alex: Really?
>>Martin: Yeah.
I can understand why you would turn off the
accelerometer when you turn the screen off.
What I don't understand is the next 0.5% of
devices which ignored the wakelock that should
allow you to wake the damn accelerometer.
>>Tim: Okay, it seems like if we could agree
that it's a bug, it would be a well-characterized
bug.
It's the case where you're trying to turn
it on when the {}machine is.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Martin: Yes.
I'm not sure if it's a bug, that's the thing.
>>Trevor: It sounds likeóI mean, it's a bug
in the sense that it's behavior that's not
well-specified.
So again, this is a really good candidate
for something that we should include as part
of the Compatibility Test Suite.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: If youóSince you already have that
spreadsheet, that's actually really good data
to pass along to our engineers so we can do
some testing on our end.
>>Martin: Yeah, sure.
>>Trevor: Probably the best thing to do: if
you go to b.android.com, just paste it in
whatever data you already have there, and
then give us the ticket number or the issue
number as a comment inóI guess in Google+,
probably the best place to put it.
Or just message me directly, Trevor Johns--
I think my name might be linked to this somewhere?
[laughs]
In any case, just let one of us know what
the issue number is with any information that
you already have.
And we can go ahead and take that and pass
it along.
Either way, I'll make sure that somebody on
the sensors teamóor actually, the CTS team
also is looking into this.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Martin: Yeah, sure, I can report this.
No problem.
>>Joe: Okay.
>>Martin: Great.
Thanks, guys.
>>Joe: You're welcome.
>>Trevor: Totally.
>>Joe: Thank you.
Anybody else in the Hangout?
Okay, let's--
>>Dan: We're putting Jared back on.
He's got another question.
>>Joe: Okay.
Go ahead, Jared.
>>Jared: This is actually a quick one.
Is Logcat guaranteed to be sequential as far
as the timing?
Like, the order of logs in Logcat.
Is that guaranteed to be the order that they
were posted in the VM?
>>Trevor: If they're on different threadsó
>>Alex: I don't think if they're on different
threads.
>>Tim: I wouldn't bet on that.
>>Jared: Okay, because that would explain
a lot of what's been driving me crazy.
>>Alex: I think Logcat has aóor the log has
a flush mechanism.
I don't remember exactly, butó
>>Jared: Because I've seenI'm seeing Logcat
messages that the order really doesn't make
sense.
You know?
>>Alex: Right.
>>Trevor: It's possible that they are getting
written in a different order than you're posting
them, ëcause they're coming from different
threads.
If you want to get around that, maybe a good
idea would be to go and include the system
time when the log message is generated as
part of your log message.
>>Jared: All right.
>>Tim: I would totally do that.
I would think that on a modern four core processor,
it would be a really, really hard to do Logcat
in the way that it'sóyou know.
Something might happen, but then you get swapped
out, right?
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: Yep.
>>Tim: Somebody else is swapped in, and then,
you know.
>>Joe: I agree.
The system time is a good way of doing it.
>>Jared: Okay.
Perfect.
>>Alex: Does Logcat have a flush method?
Do you guys know?
>>Trevor: No, it doesn't.
I don't think so.
>>Alex: Okay.
>>Tim: It's what's happening behind the scenes,
where you can't control it, right?
>>Alex: Yeah.
>>Joe: Yeah.
Thanks Jared.
Anyone else?
I haveóYou know, the reason I do this is
I have to ask the engineer if there's anybody
else in the Hangout, ëcause I can only see
one other person at a time.
>>Dan: Actually, I'm gonna put Martin back
on.
>>Joe: Okay.
Go ahead, Martin.
>>Martin: [laughs] Okay.
Just another quick one.
It's not related to sensors, but it should
be fairly easy to answer if you know anything
about it.
[clears throat] I've been having a ton of
problems with the calendar time zone thingy.
And I'm wondering if there'sóI have been
able to find one bug report on the older phones,
but theyóI feel like it still hasn't been
fixed.
So you have two methods on the calendar, right?
Iin which you can set the time zone.
You have the field zone off set, and you have
the time zone parameter with the set time
zone method that actually takes the time zone
object.
I'm just wondering if both of those methods
should work the same or not.
>>Joe: Hmm.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I'm not clearfamiliar enough
with the API to know what the difference between
those two is.
That's a really good question.
I think we're going to ask David to do some
research there, and get back to you.
I've written it down.
I'll go over questions from last week at the
beginning of the next show.
Actually, you know what?
I suppose we forgot to do that.
I have the answers to questions from last
week, too.
At some pointó
>>Joe: Right.
We can doóWe have agreed to let Tim have
his chance with sensors.
>>Trevor: Yeah, let Tim do it, and let's keep
Tim on the line here as long as we can.
Then we'll go over questions from last week
a little bit later.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Tim: There's some other ModeratoróThere're
some other sensor- related questionsó
>>Joe: Yeah, we're going to get to you in
just a sec.
We're about to come back to you.
>>Trevor: All right.
So yes.
Yeah, just a follow up on the live question:
we'll do some research.
We'll get back to you beginning of the show
next week.
We should have some more info for you.
All right.
Thanks for the question.
>>Martin: Thanks.
>>Joe: We want to use as much time of Tim's
as we can get, so we're gonna move on to the
Moderator to get some moreó
>>Tim: Sensor questions.
>>Joe: Sensor questions, yes.
Thank you.
Sensor questions.
"Recommend best practice is to get input from
sensors for a long-running application with
the display off, that does not drain the battery?"
>>Tim: Right.
So there's a few things to watch out here
for.
The reasonóOne of the reasons why sensors
drain battery is not so much that the sensor
itself consumes power, it's that it's calling
you back 100 times a second.
Or I think the slowest possible rate they
can do is 20 or 30 times a second.
That's waking up your process, looking into
it.
Unfortunately, if you look at typical sensor
callbacks, they're full of trigonometry and
math libraries and floating point.
They're not cheap.
I would really, totally not recommend leaving
the sensor running.
If I were gonna do this kind of thing, what
I would do is I would put myself into its
service and schedule myself to wake up every
so often.
Turn the sensors on for ten seconds, gather
a bunch of data, and then go back to sleep.
Now ideally, I would not do much data processing
unless there's actuallyóyou're looking for
it to wake up.
I would gather the data, stuff it in the database,
go back to sleep.
[pause]
The ratio between the amount of time you're
awake and the amount of time you're asleep,
work it out.
But if you're only awake for 5% of the time,
you're clearly not gonna hurt the battery
that much.
Now, the one thing you asked about was GPS,
and that's a different thing.
One thing to watch out for is while you're
asleep, somebody else might have gotten up
and opened up the Maps{} or done something
like that that resulted in GPS.
So what you should totally do is go and look
at some of the stuff that Reto Meier's been
publishing about how to do location efficiently.
In particular, there's this thing called the
passive location provideró
>>Trevor: Right.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Tim: --that just parasitically remembers
any locations that have come in through other
apps.
And then when you wake up, if you use that
app, you might just get a really high quality
location data right there for you, without
ever having to turn the GPS on.
I'm not gonna reiterate all the excellent
advice that Reto gave, because it goes on
for an hour.
It's a big subject.
But the regular sensors just wake up every
so often.
For their location, go and look and do what
Reto said.
>>Trevor: All right.
I have one more thing on GPS there, too.
A lot of times, what you need when you're
trying to turn GPS on doesn't actually require
GPS.
You can use the course location provider,
which will still get you, actually, a fairly
accurate location fix, but without the power
overheadit of turning the GPS radio on and
waiting for a satellite lock and all this
other stuff which takes time and CPU.
So if you can at all get away with it, use
the course location provider first, in addition
to all the other stuff like using the passive
location provider.
Definitely look through Reto's post.
But keep in mind, GPS isn't your only option
for location.
[pause]
>>Joe: Okay.
I'm looking for sensor-related stuff.
>>Tim: Yeah.
There's that oneóSorry, the next one down,
Joe, is actually different from the rest of
his.
>>Joe: Actually, the next one down foróYou
mean Jan?
>>Tim: Yes.
>>Joe: Okay.
Can youó
>>Tim: So that's actually an interesting question.
>>Joe: Yeah.
"Sensors or fragmentation.
Could you enforce on manufacturers somewhat
more stronglyó"
>>Tim: No, I'm sorry, that's not what I'm
looking at.
The one I'm looking at says, "Many sensors
return values only when they change?"?
>>Joe: Hold on for a second.
>>Trevor: I think that's further up.
It used to be.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: That's it.
>>Joe: Yep.
Here we are.
"Many sensors return values only when they
change.
Could this become part of a spec and draw
a line between sensors that do just that,
and those capable of returning the current
value as well?"
>>Tim: Right.
So up until 4.1, no.
As of now, yes.
Now, I didn't actually know that.
I've never used such a sensor, but in preparation
for this, I was going and reading this CTDD
and things like that.
And I gather that in 4.1, we did introduce
a new type of sensor that is what's called
a "streaming sensor."
That-- You just read live values out of it.
Having said that, I've never used one.
And I didn't have time to go and drill down
on it.
So they actually had to do quite a bit of
architectural work with the core sensor code
because all the stuff that had existed assumed
it was all callback based.
So the answer to Jan's question is: yes, this
could become part of spec, and it has become
part of spec, but no, I don't actually have
any specific, concrete advice.
But clearly, other people share your desire
for that kind of sensor.
>>Joe: Okay.
I'm trying to see if there's any other questionsóOh,
here's one that's not from anybody that has
asked a question before.
"Are there any use cases for sensors and apps
which you feel have been underutilized by
developers?"
>>Tim: WhichóSorry, I didn't hear you, Joe.
>>Joe: "Are there any use cases for sensors
and apps which you feel have been underutilized
by developers?"
>>Tim: Oh, absolutely.
It's what I would callówhat most people would
call Gestures, but that already has been taken
by another piece of Android, so we can't call
it Gestures.
So I've been calling it Kinetics.
This is the classic case of "shake to undo."
Or there's a bunch of short, simple gestures
you can do that matches "chop left", "chop
forward", "chop back" [slapping sound] "slap
the front", [slapping sound] "slap the back",
[slapping sound] "slap the side" kind of thing.
And I'm actually in the background, working
on an app that has no screen controls at all,
and is entirely controlled by those kinds
of kinetics.
And actually, I noticedóI discovered, once
I got over the hump, they're not that hard
to write.
And there's not that many of them out in the
market, so I totally recommend people do that,
because not only is it really cool when it
works, it might well differentiate you from
the other 500,000 or however many it is apps
on the market that haven't been clever enough
to do that.
How muchó
>>Trevor: I remember talking about an app
I saw a while back where you could take your
phone and flip it over.
So if it's face down on your desk, it would
silence.
>>Joe: Hmm.
>>Tim: Yeah!
>>Joe: Okay.
>>Tim: In fact, we did a talk at Google IO
with Annika {}Ankur Kotwal and Tony Chan.
And AnnikaAnkur wrote a little blackjack app
with dealer apps and player apps.
You would fold your cards by turning them
overóturning your phone over.
And you would say, "Hit me!" by moving your
hand over the phone.
And things like that.
It felt really great to watch it work.
And when the dealer was gonna turn his cards
over so you could start counting, he would
just flip the phone up, and they would flip
over.
It wasóIt's really, really nice.
I don't know about you, but I get tired of
apps with buttons all over the screens, and
trying to .
>>Joe: Well, I would agree with you.
I would also point out that there's a lot
of circumstances in which you want to protect
the device, whatever type of device it is,
from the environment.
Which means that you can't directly use the
touchscreen, but you can still use the accelerometer.
[pause]
So any other comments about this question?
No?
In that case, where do we stand?
Or do we have anybody in the Hangout waiting
for a question?
All right, let's go back here and see where
we are.
>>Dan: Actuallyó
>>Joe: Oh!
>>Dan: Actually, we have a hand just raised.
>>Joe: Okay.
>>Dan: Looks like Alex.
Alex, you want to go on to the air?
>>Hangout Alex: Yeah, if I can.
>>Dan: Here we go.
>>Joe: Okay.
Hello, Alex.
>>Hangout Alex: Okay.
Hey.
Talking about Gestures, or Kinetics, as you
toldcalled.
My question is about the better wayóDo you
hear me well?
>>Tim: Talk a little slower, please.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Hangout Alex: Okay.
The main question is: how do you prefer to
recognize the gestures?
I mean, basically, they're parameter data.
You can use a few other sensors, like linear
acceleration.
You know?
And they actually provide to you the acceleration
itself.
And if you want to direct the movement itself,
to draw, for example, a symbol, you should
double integrate it.
Double integration, as maybe you all know,
is really not accurate.
As I know, in the device, it cannot be used
in duration, and just required to be used
in raw sensor data.
However, maybe is there some way of some fielders,
for example, which will help to make better
accuracy for predicting the movement?
>>Joe: Hmm.
>>Tim: We gave a talk on more or less exactly
that question at Google IO this year.
So if you go to Google IO and look for "A
Sensitive Side toof Android," there's both
the video and slides with lots of links.
So to address what you said, [pause] I actually
did a lot of this coding myself.
And there's also an app I published to the
Play Store called Sensplore.
There's a link to it in the talks.
What it does is it allows you to shake the
phone around, and it captures a bunch of sensory
data and puts it in a CSV file and emails
it to you.
So you can make graphs of what the values
are.
Now, in answer to your question, I prefer--
For gesture detection, there are some calculations
you can do if you save theóWhich one is it?
It's one of the sensors.
It's the linear acceleration sensor.
>>Hangout Alex: That one?
>>Tim: I'll have to go and look whichever
it is.
Anyhow, you can save the data, and then you
can call a routine on it that will detect
change in an angle along the three axes.
Delta angle around the x, y, and z axes.
And I actually found that one was the most
useful in detecting simple hand gestures like
shaking and twisting and that kind of stuff.
You have to watch out for a bunch of things.
The data is messy as it comes off the sensors,
so you have to do some filtering and stuff.
Now, the last thing you talked about is pretty
hard.
So I'd like to be able to draw letters of
fire in the air, or something like that.
That's really hard.
The quality of the data coming out-- I'm not
sure that can actually be done.
I tried to do that for a month or two, and
I couldn't do it.
If you look at something like the Ninentdo
Wii or the Connect, the way they work is they
have a fixed point, like a camera or the IR
sensor, something standing still and watching
you move around.
So for them, it's actually much, much easier.
I've never actually seen a mobile app on any
platform that really allows you to do a good
three dimensional motion tracking of the device.
If somebody could figure out how to do that
and make it work, I think that would be a
great {} service.
I wasn't smart enough.
>>Trevor: This reminds me of another question
that I actually saw earlier in Moderator.
That was theóI can't remember who asked it,
but the question was, "Are there any good
libraries out there to go and do Gesture detections?"
Right now, we just provide the low-level libraries
to go and read sensor data.
Now, I'm not actually familiar with any libraries
out there that provide prepackaged Gestures.
Tim, are you aware of anything?
>>Tim: Well, I'm aware in the negative sense
in that I looked really hard for them, and
I didn't [laughs] find anything very much
to speak of.
There are 27 different libraries out there
that will detect a shake.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Tim: All by doing the (x2 + y2 + z2)(1/2)
and detecting absolute values and acceleration.
But no, I think that it's actually a fairly
weak area.
>>Trevor: Okay.
So that's actually a probablyóeven going
back to the last question, too, on open areas
for development.
So if somebody wants to do some open source
work that really benefits the community, I
think this isóIt's an open area for development.
Write the library that does gesture recognition.
>>Joe: Right.
There'só
>>Alex: Some pretty fat gestures.
>>Joe: There's a question here from Pablo
about standard sensor-based gesture recognizers
as part of the API.
>>Trevor: Yeah, that was the one.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Alex: Right.
>>Joe: And myóI don't know for sure, but
I think we agree that the likelihood of that
happening anytime soon is not high.
But it's certainly a place where other people
could make thea contribution to Android, for
sure.
I think, as people pointed out, not much has
been done here yet.
And I don't think very much has been done
anywhere in the space for any types of devices
yet.
We just haven't gotten used to the idea that
these sensors are available and can be used
to communicate with devices.
Jared.
>>JaredTim: I have one small sample piece
of code that you might want to check out in
that Sensplore app that's open sourced on
.
It's got a flip recognizer to recognize flipping
up and flipping back.
>>Joe: Okay.
>>Jared: It's not an app or a shared library
or anything like that.
It's just a bunch of Java code.
But it seems to work pretty well.
>>Joe: Okay.
>>Jared: I actually have a comment to this,
guys.
It kinda goes to what Tim was talking about,
where he worked on it for a long time and
struggled with it.
Basically, what you're talking about doing
is an inertial guidance system.
>>Tim: Exactly.
>>Jared: And missiles, aircraft, rockets,
they all do it.
They do it incredibly well.
But they're talking about something where
they're measuringóThey want to be a couple
of feet accurate over several miles, and you're
talking about millimeters of accuracy in a
foot, half a meter.
It could be done, but those same devices that
are actually doing it, they were purpose-built
for that task.
So their sensors are much more accurate.
Their analog-digital conversion's much more
accurate.
They're able to do a lot more processing because
they have DSP chips to do all this math.
And much more.
You know, real time.
So I think, in theory, it's capable.
I just doubt that the Android phone possesses
the hardware required to do it.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: That's a very good point.
Thank you.
>>Tim: Yeah.
>>Joe: Yeah, thank you, Jared.
Okay.
Anybody else in the Hangout?
No?
Okay, let's move on, then.
There's another question in here from Jan
in Prague.
"Could you enforce on the manufacturers a
somewhat more standardized behavior of sensors?
That is, even Galaxy Nexus has issues with
proximity sensors returning nonsense when
covered with, say, paper."
>>Tim: Well, there is one thing specifically
about proximity sensors.
The proximity sensor is well-known by people
who've done these things to be a very blunt-edged
instrument.
In general, you can't count on much more than
it detecting "there's something in front"
or "there's not something in front."
Now, it claims to read upout in centimeters
or something like that, but in fact, it's
just not up to that.
I think we addressed Jan's question initially
in that the CDDV doesn't really promise very
much, to the extent that there are obvious
glitches that really should be better.
The  test could certainly
be beefed up {}in the open source project.
>>Trevor: I'll add one more thing on top of
that, too.
Having done some robotics work before, sensors
are very noisy.
That's the nature of the physical world, then
it's just the reality of working with sensor
data.
We can go and give you tools like virtual
sensors to go and help clean them up, but
at some level, there's always gonna be some
inaccuracy here, and there's always gonna
be a little bit of extra work required converting
data from sensors into something very clean
that you're app location makes sense of.
That's just the nature of the field.
>>Joe: Yeah.
And I would also say that there's various
waysóthere's various types of sensors that
you can use to do the same type of measurement.
In robotics, at least, the question becomes,
"Which is the best one to use for your particular
application?"
Just because you've got a color sensor doesn't
mean that that's necessarily the best way
of sensing the particular quality of some
material that you have in front of you.
There might be another sensor that you could
choose that is better for that particular
application.
And those are the sort of trade-offs that
you make in robotics all the time.
>>Tim: Let me make two specific points.
>>Joe: Go ahead.
>>Tim: On the Android devices, it seems to
be conventional wisdom that the higher tech,highest
quality sensor is the gyroscope.
The data that comes out of the gyroscope are
generally considered to be, relative to all
the others, cleaner and nicer and easier to
work with.
Second thing is that for every category of
sensor data I trapped pretty well, I ended
up having to write somewhere in the
a little circular buffer where, instead of
working with the raw sensor data, I would
end up working with the average of the last
mn.
So every time you got a new one, you could
put it in the buffer, average the latest mn,
and give that value instead.
And by the way, I found that mn = 5 was a
really good value for a lot of sensors.
>>Joe: Now, that's a really good piece of
advice.
Really good information to have.
And we have one more question I'd like to
get out of you, Tim.
Someone posted a question that says, "Were
there any sensor related behind-the-scenes
changes on 4.1?
You mentioned one already.
Are there any others you can think of?"
>>Tim: There was a ton of refactoring that
went into that.
I don't knowóTrevor, remember {unintelligible
name} was workingóor no, Matthias {unintelligible
name} was working on it.
They did a ton of work.
At some point, in the flow of somewhere between
ICS and Jelly Bean, the quality of the data
was really qualitatively improved.
>>Trevor: Right.
Yeah, and that's not stuff that you're gonna
see so much in the API.
It really is implementation changes.
>>Joe: Okay.
Okay, let me goóSince we've been hopping
all over the place today, I have to get my
bearings here again.
I think what we want to do is, if we don't
have anybody else waiting for a sensor-related
question in the Hangoutónoóthen we'll move
on to some questions that don't necessarily
involve sensors.
Let's go see here.
[pause]
"The best set of test devices"óthis is from
Napster in Indiaó"What is the best set of
test devices that an independent developer
can own?
For example, Nexus 7, Galaxy Nexus, Nexus
S, Motorola Droid, the screen density of theseies
and API versions are my criterion.
Thanks."
>>Trevor: Okay.
Actually, Alex, do you want to start off with
this one?
>>Alex: Yeah, sure.
First thing to note is that there isn't a
specific setóthere isn't a set of very specific
devices that you want in your test family.
What you really want to be looking for is,
like you mentioned, a set of devices that
matches those facts, each of those criteria.
So you want a range of API versions.
You want a range of screen sizes.
More importantly, also important is you want
a range of GPUs, of graphics chips.
And there're these families that you want
to follow.
So probably, you want at least one tablet,
one large phone, one small phone, depending
on how universal you want to be, probably
a Google TV.
Try toóI would say go as far back as FROYO.
Get a blend all the way from FROYO to Jelly
Bean, and new devices-- or devices with new
API versions as they come out.
And I'm sure I'm missing a couple of criteria
here.
Trevor?
>>Trevor: Sorry, you mentionedóWhat was the
list you mentioned?
>>Alex: GPU, API version, screen size, oh,
and screen density.
>>Trevor: Right.
Yeah, I'd say those are the big ones.
The GPU is one that I think a lot of people
often miss, because it's not somethingóit's
something inside the phone you need to think
about.
But there's four major GPU vendors.
Try to have a device from each of those.
Just because so much is hardware accelerator
right now, even when you don't think you're
using Open GL, you probably are.
And then otherwise, just get a good mix of
phones that represent the different density
buckets, screen size buckets, and API levels.
The Nexus devices in general are usually pretty
good ones, if you're just gettingóif you
need something to get started with.
A lot of our internal development is done
on them for obvious reasons.
It doesn't cover everything, but it does cover
pretty wide spectrum out there.
And on top of that, just devices that are
popular.
If there's a lot of users using the phone,
it might make sense for you to have one of
those, too.
Now, that being said, you don't necessarily
need to have a ton of phones.
In fact, you definitely don't need to have
a ton of phones if you want to do Android
development.
We try very hard to go and make sure that
everything behaves consistently across devices,
but there are cases, especially with things
like Textures and Open GL where you tend to
see a bit more differences because of the
nature of GPUs.
So just watch out for that.
One thing.
If you do want to get access to a lot of different
devices, and you don't have a big budget,
[dinging] of course, there is the emulator
if you're just doing basic API level testing,
screen test testing, the emulator will get
you access to all of that.
You don't need physical devices in many cases.
But if you do find that you do, there are
a number of third party vendors that provide
access toóremote access to the devices.
So off the top of my head, I think a DeviceAnywhere
and Bitbar are two really popular ones.
They have very different products.
But you pay them a small fee and upload your
APK to them, and they'll go and either let
you run it on individual devices one at a
time, or run automated tests across the entire
suite of devices.
You can get some really good data that way,
too.
>>Alex: I would say: one of the things, also:
don't discount the fact that you can build
as many different emulators on your own local
developmentó
>>Joe: Right.
>>Alex: And machines as you want.
>>Trevor: It's true.
And the emulators have gotten a lot better,
too.
>>Alex: Right.
You can build a gingerbread device of any
size.
You can build a Jelly Bean device of any size,
any density you want.
It's not at a point where you can emulate
any GPU chip you want, so you can't have NVIDIA
next to a Polycom next to a whatever.
>>Trevor: No.
>>Alex: But you can have aóYou can automate
a thing where you spin up a tablet emulator
next to a phone emulator, take a couple of
screen shots, and then compare afterwards.
Or run a test suite.
>>Trevor: And maybe if you haven't used the
emulator in quite a while or haven't been
following the developments there, we've added
hardware acceleration as well as virtualization
support.
Basically, that means the emulator's actually
gotten to the point where it's not painful
to use.
[laughs] It actually feels as fast as a normal
phone in a lot of cases.
So it really is a useful development tool,
and if you don't find yourself using an emulator,
now might be a good time to give it another
try.
>>Joe: Right.
Okay?
Great, thank you very much.
>>Dan: Hey guys, a couple of people in the
Hangout are just asking for a recap from last
weekó
>>Joe: Yes.
Okay.
Yes.
Go ahead.
>>Trevor: Excellent.
>>Joe: Let's do that now.
>>Trevor: All right.
Well, not so much a recap, but a list of questions
we couldn't answer.
So there we two of those from last week.
The first one was a question about aóActually,
for those who weren't with us last week, the
topic was web development on Android.
And one of the questions was about a library
that was announced at Google IO for syncing
preferences across different devices.
And particularly, they wanted to know if there
were any updates on that.
So I spoke to , who was
the engineer who gave the talk where that
was announced.
He told me that the team is still working
on it.
They don't have anything that they can announce
at this time, but it still is under app development.
So hopefully sometime in the near future,
we'll hear something.
Just stay tuned and we'll let you know as
soon as there's something new that we can
share there.
The other question was about parsing JSON
data on devices with limited memory.
In particular, are there any streaming stacks
file parsers for JSON?
And we have two recommendations for you: the
first one is actually already built into Android.
So as of Honeycomb, API level 11, we have
an android.util.json reader, which is a streaming
JSON parser built into the system that should
do exactly what you want.
Now, if you're on a device that's pre-Honeycomb,
we would recommend using a library called
GSON.
G as in Google.
It turns out that JSON reader is actually
derived from GSON, so the two have very similar
interfaces.
If you're looking for something that's backwards
compatible and easy to either swap out at
runtime or upgrade to later, GSON's definitely
a good choice.
We picked it for the framework, so can't go
too wrong.
And that were the two unanswered questions
from last week.
>>Joe: Okay.
Now, we have also talked about some audio
problems that we had at the beginning of last
week.
>>Trevor: Yes.
>>Joe: Will people be able to look at the
Youtube recording?
>>Trevor: They will once the Youtube video
goes up.
I believe there'sóDaniel can correct me if
I'm wrong, but I believe there's some processing
errors, and it's stillóor some processing
delays, rather, and it's still in the queue
waiting to get uploaded.
So we do have a recording of itó
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: --and as soon as the areaóIf, for
some reason, Youtube isn't able to go and
post the video, we can just post the recorded
version.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Dan: Yeah, that's correct as far as I know.
I actually have another question from the
Hangout real quickó
>>Joe: Go ahead.
>>Dan: --before we close for today.
I'm gonna put Akil on.
I think that's how you pronounce it?
Correct me if I'm wrong.
>>Joe: Please do.
>>Dan: One second.
[pause]
>>Joe: Ahhh.
>>Dan: Whoops.
I see you guys.
There we go.
>>Joe: There he is!
Hello!
>>Trevor: Howdy.
>>Akil: Hello.
Hello, can you hear me?
>>Trevor: Yes.
>>Joe: Yes.
>>Akil: Okay, this is a follow-up to last
week's question.
I'm a beginner to Android development, and
I've been using the API guides.
Not straight through, though.
Do you have any suggestions on some good parts
of it that I should make sure I have covered?
Like, I have done the fundamentals, and the
activity section except for loaders and user
interface stuff, but I'm having trouble differentiating
what is something to read for reference later,
or what are the fundamentals.
>>Joe: I remember this question from last
week.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
Well, I think the question from last week
was actuallyóWell, no, there were two questions
recently.
One was "What would be good things to read?"
and another one was "Would you recommend reading
through all of the API guide?"
So yeah, fundamentals is definitely a place
to start.
That's why it's called fundamentals, right?
[laughs] Loaders, definitely.
You'll definitely want to read up on loaders
and UI when you get a chance, both of which
are extremely important for modern Android
development.
I guess UI has always been important.
As far as other things worth notingóNow,
SequelLite, is that-- I can't remember
if that's part of the fundamental section
or not, but you'll definitely need to be familiar
with that.
Other things worth knowing: Binder is probably
nothing you need to know to begin with, but
something you'll probably run into eventually,
since that's the RPC mechanism for Android.
Let's see, what are some other really good
sections worth noting?
Shared preferences.
Definitely a good section to read up on.
Let's see, what else?
>>Joe: I would say that it's difficult to
give you detailed advice without knowing what
sort of things you're trying to do.
If you're just trying to learn everything
there is to know about Android, my approach
to it is always to suggest that people pick
a project that they want to do, and then go
off and try to do it.
And, in addition, read the API guides as you
go along trying to do that project to learn
about activities and how activities interact
with each other.
If I was gonna name it, I would say activities,
intents, servicesó
>>Trevor: Yep.
>>Joe: --and also shared preferences andó
>>Alex: Fragments, probably.
>>Trevor: Oh, fragments.
Definitely.
>>Alex: Yeah.
>>Joe: Fragments.
Fragments might be very useful as well.
I think you can wait on those until after
you've gotten through some simple exercises.
And keep in mind that we have a whole set
of Android training that you can do in conjunction
with any of the API guides that you read.
>>Trevor: Right.
>>Alex: I would say, to get a solid foundation,
the Android training is split into a basic
training section and an advanced topic section.
Basic training is the stuff that everyone
should try to learn all of.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Alex: ëCause it's the stuff that comes
up in almost every Android application past
a certain size that you're going to write.
The advanced topic stuff is also very useful
to know, but it only matters to your application
some of the time.
So I would say definitely cover the Getting
Started section of Android training, and that
will cover a really good, solid foundation
for you.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: The training section is probably
a little bit closer to what you're trying
to do, too.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: That's the section that really is
meant to be read sequentially, whereas the
API guide and especially the reference are
moreóit's more reference material.
You jump to the sections you need as you need
them.
>>Akil: Yeah.
I'm writing a course organizing app for students
and stuff.
>>Joe: Mmhmm.
>>Akil: That's what I'm a
project to work on.
So I was just wondering what should I basically
cover, and what's the next thing to do?
But thanks for shedding some light on that.
That really helps.
Awesome.
>>Joe: Okay.
Great.
Thank you.
[watch beeps] Do we have anybody else out
there?
>>Dan: Nope.
>>Joe: Okay.
Do we have time for one last question?
>>Dan: I think we can spare another minute
or so.
We're a little over time, but that's not a
problem.
>>Joe: Okay.
Do you want to try and tackle this last question
here, sitting here?
>>Trevor: Eh, we can go ahead and do it.
I meanó
>>Joe: Okay.
>>Trevor: --there's not much I can say on
that, but let's go ahead.
>>Joe: Okay.
Let's at least read it.
"It took three weeks for developer to support,
respond, and reinstate the Reddit sync application
after a trademark misunderstanding.
What are you doing to enhance developer relations
and fix these unacceptable response times
from support?"
>>Trevor: Okay.
Like I said, I can't say too much on this
particular issue.
App reviews are private issues between us
and the developer in question.
We have been in contact with that developer,
and we have been since the beginning, so there
is definitely a dialog going on there.
I just can't really publicly say what's going
on there.
Like I said, it's between us and the developer.
In general, thoughóI mean, first off, we
are aware that there was some concern in the
community about this particular app.
And we're looking what we can do there to
improve the process in the future.
And on a more general note, I just want to
emphasize: if you are a developer on Google
Play, make sure you read through the terms
of services, and make sure that you don't
have anything in your app which either violates
those or our content guidelines, because then
the review team can get involved.
It's a messy situation for everyone involved.
Something that's best to avoid if possible.
But again, we are aware of this particular
case, and we're looking into ways to improve
it for the future, improve the process for
the future.
I think that pretty much covers everything
we can say on that.
>>Joe: Okay.
Any other comments for today?
All right.
With that, we will say goodbye to you and
see you again this time next week.
Please send in your questions to Moderator
and, if you want to ask us questions on the
air, please feel free.
Until then.
>>Trevor: All right.
See you, everyone.
[pause]